within everything around us there are
hundreds of ideas waiting to be found
we've just got to look closer at these
things I'm Dominic Wilcox I'm an artist
designer and inventor and I'm on a
mission to inspire the world's children
to become the inventors of our futures
and we've come here to Sheffield High
School and I've come here to ask the
children here to come up with their own
invention ideas now who knows what an
inventor is what does an inventor do I'm
going to show the children my inventions
I don't like it when the tea is too hot
and so I decided to join a fan onto this
saucer and try and inspire them to start
thinking creatively and to think about
what invention is and what it is to be
an inventor children have a natural
imagination that is so free and
unrestricted children have that freedom
of thought that I think adults can
actually learn from will then look for
the most interesting surprising
imaginative ideas and make the best one
into a real thing by working with local
makers and manufacturers here in the
city of Sheffield there was one idea
that came out which was an a pair of
wellington boots that when it's a bit
slippy outside you can press a button
and some spikes emerge from the bottom
of the soles to give your shoes a better
grip that child will meet the
professional maker welcome Isabelle
genius inventor and then that gets
turned into a real thing then you pull
what ring and flesh dough
it's just like something that I thought
is actually real it's like come alive
imagine if we could inspire all of the
world's children to become doors
innovative's people with the imagination
to solve the world's problems I think
that will make the world such a better
place